قال مسؤول افغاني للجزيره ان السلطات
الافغانيه اغلقت معبر جسر الحرير الحدودي
في ولايه نمروز مع ايران بعد اشتباكات
استمرت عده ساعات بين الطرفين استخدمت
فيها الاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله وافادت
مصادر افغانيه وايرانيه بتوقف الاشتباكات
التي كانت اندلعت في وقت سابق بين
الجانبين فيما اكدت وكاله مهر الايرانيه
وقوع الاشتباكات وقال مصدر عسكري افغاني
للجزيره ان القوات الايرانيه اطلقت قذائف
هاون على المطار القديم لمدينه
زرنج عاصمه نمروز
للمزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من كابو
المراسل الجزيره ناصر شديد ومعنا من طهران
مراسل الجزيره نور الدين نور الدين دغرير
اهلا بكم ابدى مع نور الدين غير والروايه
الايرانيه عما جرى
هناك مجموعه من التفاصيل تتحدث عنها اداره
الحدود وقوات الحدود الايرانيه فيما يخص
الاشتباك الذي حصل اليوم على مستوى الحدود
ما بين ايران وافغانستان الروايه
الايرانيه تتحدث على ان كانت هناك مجموعه
مسلحه كانت تريد التوجه الى داخل الاراضي
الايرانيه تم توجيه تحذير لها من قبل قوات
حرس الحدود ايرانيه لكن لم تلتفت لي هذا
التحذير فبدات
بالرد على هذه المجموعه كذلك كان هناك
اطلاق نار من الجهه الافغانيه باتجاه
القوات الايرانيه هذه هي الروايه بذلك بدا
هذا الاشتباك الحاصل ما بين القوتين ما
يميز هذا الاشتباك الذي حدث اليوم هو في
طبيعه الاسلحه المستعمله في السابق كانت
العديد من الاشتباكات تقع بين الفينه
والاخرى يتم استعمال الاسلحه الخفيفه من
الرشاشات لكن ما يتم الحديث عنه اليوم انه
تم استعمال اسلحه ثقيله واسلحه متوسطه
واسلحه فما يعطيه على انطباعا على ان
المواجهات هي مواجهات كانت شديده لكن هنا
قوه حرس الحدود الايرانيه الايرانيون
ينفون بانهم كانوا قد استهدفوا ايا من
المطارات داخل الاراضي الافغانيه كان
الحديث على ان القوات الايرانيه استعملت
الصواريخ هنا يتحدث الايرانيون انه خلال
هذه المواجهات لم يتم استعمال اي من
الصواريخ وانما تمت الاشتباك على مستوى
الحدود باستعمال المدفعيات اسلحه ثقيله
واسلحه متوسطه يبدو ان هناك تدخل على
المستوى الدبلوماسي ما بين المسؤولين
الايرانيين في السفاره الايرانيه في كابول
مع مسؤولي وزاره الدفاع وكذلك وزاره
الخارجيه الافغانيه وهو ما ادمت الى ايقاف
هذا الاشتباك لكن عبد السلام يمكن القول
بان هذه الاشتباكات يبدو انها اصبحت جزء
من الحياه الاعتياديه على مستوى الحدود ما
بين ايران وما بين افغانستان وليست المره
الاولى وذلك بعناوين متعدده تحدث هذه
الاشتباكات مره بمحاوله منع مهاجرين غير
نظاميين الى داخلي الاراضي الايرانيه مره
اخرى بمنع عمليه التهريب التي تتم عبر
الحدود او بمرات عبر منع تسلل مسلحين الذي
ترى طهران بانه يشكل تهديدا لامنها
القانون وبالتالي لابد من الرد على اي
تهديد ما صدر اليوم بشكل واضح من قبل
اداره الحدود والقوات الحدود الايرانيه
للقوات الايرانيه المنتشره على الحدود وهي
التدخل بقوه لمنع اي استهداف للحدود
الايرانيه ربما تبدو هذه الرساله الاولى
التي تصدر بهذه الشكل وبهذا العباره عن عن
طريق رئيس قوات الشرطه في ايران وعن طريق
نائبهم عبر اعطاء اوامر لهذه القوات
بالتعامل مع اي تهديد يستهدف هذه المنطقه
اذا ربما هذه هي الصوره لكن يمكن القول
بانها انتهت لحد الساعه لكن هل ستتكرر
يبدو ان الامر يرتبط بطبيعه هذه التهديدات
التي تنظر اليها ايران وكذلك كيف سيتعامل
قوه الايرانيه مع اي محاوله لضرب القانون
على مستوى الحدود كما يقول المسؤوليه هنا
بحسب الروايتين هناك توقف للاشتباكات ماذا
تقول السلطات الافغانيه ناصر شديد ربما
يوضح لنا وجهه نظر افغانستان فيما جرى
بنسبه للحكومه الافغانيه تقول بان من بدا
اطلاق الرصاص والنار هو الجانب الايراني
طبعا هذا الاشتباك الثالث عشر بين الطرفين
منذ وصول الحكومه الجديده لست الحكم قبل
نحو سنتين لا يمكن عبد السلام قراءه
المشهد او قراءه ما حصل اليوم بمعزل عن
التصريحات الاخيره
بالرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس الذي قال
بان على الحكومه الافغانيه او على حكام
افغانستان ان يعطوا ايران حقه في المياه
والا سيكون هناك تصرف هذه هذا الامر لربما
قبل نحو ختامن عشر من هذا الشهر هذه
التصريحات التي حصلت او تم صرح بها رئيسي
في ولايه سيستان بالاضافه وايضا في زياره
له لولايتي سيستان وبلوشستان هي التي
يعني زادت من هذا التوتر صرح بعد ذلك
الوزير الخارجيه
الافغاني امير خان متقي وقال بان
افغانستان تلتزم باتفاقيه
بالاضافه قال بان هذه الامور يجب ان تحل
على طاوله المفاوضات ولا يجب ان يكون هناك
اي خلافات بين الطرفين وهذا الامر لا يجب
ان يعني يركن الى التصريحات الاعلاميه
والتراشق الاعلامي بين الطرفين تحاول
افغانستان ان تهدئ الامر لكن بلا شك
التصاعد حده الاشتباكات اليوم بقصف مطار
قديم في
مدينه
زرانك بالاضافه الى سوق ايضا شعبي هذا
الامر
استمر تقريبا اربع ساعات من الاشتباكات
لكن في عصر اليوم وعاده الامور الى حالها
لكن لربما تحصل هناك
مناوشات بين الطرفين ان لم يكن هناك اتفاق
بين الطرفين والجلوس الى طاوله مفاوضات
لتحل المشاكل الحدوديه وايضا مشكله المياه
بين الطرفين نعم
من كابول ناصر شديد ايضا شكر موصول كان
معنا من طهران